[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous recevons dans le cadre de cette
semaine de la découverte des
collaborateurs stagiaires sur notre
chantier pour les métiers d'électricité
de plomberie et de chauffage is non
collaborateurs chef de chantier et
conducteurs de travaux était comme
toujours enchantés de participer à ce
genre d'événement parce que c'est pour
eux l'opportunité de partager leur
passion de faire découvrir leur métier
au sein de au sein du chantier
j'accompagne les opérationnels de l'opé
ats dans la mise en oeuvre d'une partie
de leur stratégie rse sur la question de
l'insertion
l'idée c'est que le bas les six
stagiaires qui sont actuellement sur les
chanter plus comment ces démissions dès
la semaine prochaine sont différents de
poste afin de la fois de réaliser leur
d'heures d'insertion mais je crois que
des binômes se sont déjà formés ça a
bien marché entre certains on a toujours
voilà plaisir de participer à ces
rencontres pour batailler vinci énergie
cette semaine de la découverte des
métiers est aussi l'occasion de tendre
la main vers des personnes qui parfois
était un peu éloigné des métiers de
l'emploi
nous espérons que cette semaine de la
découverte des métiers permettra à ces
stagiaires de s'intégrer durablement
dans les métiers de la construction
chez vinci cette action qui a été menée
justement cette semaine sur une semaine
de découverte des métiers du btp
elle a été organisée dans le cadre d'un
dispositif qui est beaucoup plus large
j'en appelle dispositif d'insertion
sociale qui est intégrée dans notre
politique rse donc une responsabilité
sociétale de l'établissement l'idée de
ça c'est de permettre à des publics en
difficulté soient sociales soient
professionnels d'accéder ou de retourner
au travail via des clauses d'insertion
qu'on s'impose d'abord à inclure dans
nos marchés de travaux mais également
qu'on impose à tous maîtres d'ouvragé
qui intervient sur nos projets et ces
clauses
elle impose quoi elle impose qui est 5 %
du montant total hors taxes des marchés
qu'ils soient traduits en oeuvre
d'insertion je pense que cette semaine a
été correctement enrichissante
moi qui est sans emploi actuellement
donc ça permet de me remettre un peu en
scène et puis de repartir à sur des
horreurs qui me correspond vraiment bien
maintenant c'est à moi de faire mes
réflexions et de le voir ce qui
m'intéresse vraiment si c'est gautier si
ces traceurs si c'est autre chose
donc voila mais voilà cette semaine a
été vraiment très bénéfique pour moi
[Musique]